In a startup's life, there is no single
day that will not bring a new challenge.
So what are sort of the common
challenges that students will face
as they're on their path
to monetization nirvana?
>> There are three main ones:
acquisition, retention, and earning.
Acquisition, this is not an easy step.
How can you put your product in front
of enough users so some of them, 4% or
less, will convert and pay for it?
In many cases, you should focus and
narrow this search.
Less is more here.
If you can focus on a niche segment in
the market, you will get a better chance
to reach the users who
are willing to try your product.
Second, exciting your audience.
Surprise them with your quality.
It's easy to say how to do.
Nevertheless you want to do it.
You wish to invest in their
attention of your users.
And a known way to do it is by
creating wonderful experience.
Users love quality and simplicity.
Third, earning in commerce,
make it easy for them to pay.
In mobile eCommerce there's lots
of forms with lots of fields.
We go into more details on
how to reduce the friction
in that process a bit later.
In app purchases, charge the right users
with the right offer at the right time.
There are many user segments and
each deserve its own customize offering.
For example, in a mobile gaming app, 5%
of the users drove 95% of the revenue.
So it was a smart move to improve
the offering for these 5%.
Ads, Do your best to use ads that
enhance the user experience.